zdf heute live herzlich willkommen alec
baldwin hat mit scharfer munition
geschossen dass es eine der erkenntnisse
die ermittler und staatsanwaltschaft
heute bekannt gegeben haben und damit
ist auch klar die kamerafrau halina
hudgens wurde durch eine kugel aus
seiner film waffe getötet wir sprechen
gleich mit einem deutschen waffenmeister
über das was da am filmset passiert ist
und schalten in die usa aber das sind
erstmal die infos von staatsanwältin
marie concorde ließ die staatsanwältin
von santa fe und aidan mendoza der
sheriff des landkreises santa fe
wir haben zwei weitere personen
identifiziert die die geladene waffe in
ihren händen hatten und oder die waffe
prüften bevor borg wenn sie abfeuerte
diese zwei personen sind die waffen
meisten henry terrace und regieassistent
david holz alle drei personen haben bei
den untersuchungen kooperiert
wir glauben auch dass wir die
patronenhülse des projektils haben die
aus der waffe abgefeuert wurde dass
tatsächlich aus blei bestehende
projektil wurde aus der schulter von
mister sosa entfernt
ich treffe keine überstürzten
entscheidungen und keine überstürzten
urteile ich hatte mich an fakten die
auch beweisen beruht auf glaubhafte
zeugenaussagen und ich kann nicht genug
betonen wie wichtig weitere ermittlungen
sind in einem fall des wohl ernst als
auch komplex ist
janina niebergall ist für uns
zugeschaltet aus washington in den usa
an dieser stelle nochmal an sie liebe
userinnen und user wenn sie fragen haben
auch an nina oder an den waffenmeister
später in der sendung dann schreiben sie
bitte ihre fragen und kommentare wie
immer in die kommentare oder wenn sie
die app nutzen an die eingeblendete e
mail adresse nina du hast die
pressekonferenz verfolgt was bedeutet
das denn jetzt
ja das bedeutet wir haben gerade schon
gehört dass tatsächlich alina hudgens
mit scharfer munition erschossen wurde
das heißt wir sprechen hier nicht von
einer platzpatrone nicht von einer
attrappe sohn sondern so gehen die
ermittler aktuell aus wir sprechen von
einer echten bleikugel und das war in
dieser deutlichkeit bislang noch nicht
bekannt die begrifflichkeiten gegner in
den letzten tagen etwas auseinander aber
das ist jetzt eben die sehr erstaunliche
neuigkeit weil man eigentlich das sagen
seit tagen alle experten davon ausgehen
sollte dass scharfe munition in einem
filmset nichts zu suchen hat
platzpatronen ja attrappen jahr aber
eben keine scharfe munition
genau das ist eine frage die ganz viele
userinnen und user hier im chat auch
bewegt und die wir dann gleich mit dem
waffenmeister der sich hier auskennt mit
diesen fragen auch noch einmal im detail
besprechen können nina jetzt richten
sich natürlich alle augen auf alec
baldwin und die frage inwiefern erden
eine anklage zu erwarten hat gab es
irgendwas an den statements der
staatsanwältinnen heute was darauf
hindeuten lässt dass so etwas
vorbereitet wird gegen ihn
ja das ist irgendwo im jetzigen
zeitpunkt noch schwer zu sagen also wir
haben jetzt schon immer wieder gehört
eine strafrechtliche anklage ist nicht
ausgeschlossen allerdings sagen bislang
staatsanwältin und sheriff noch nichts
dazu wer denn eine strafrechtliche
anklage zu befürchten hat alec baldwin
es natürlich derjenige der geschossen
hat und als solcher steht er natürlich
im mittelpunkt des interesses und er ist
nicht nur schauspieler sondern er war
auch oder ist auch produkts produzent
dieses films das heißt auch in dieser
funktion
könnte er eine teil verantwortung tragen
für die
sicherheitsvorkehrungen am set aber es
stehen auch noch zwei weitere personen
im mittelpunkt des interesses das haben
wir auch gerade schon gehört das eine
ist die waffen meisterin die eben auch
eine verantwortung trägt für die
sicherheit von waffen an einem filmset
und der regler assistent der soll die
waffe an alec baldwin übergeben haben
und gesagt haben gold kann also die
waffe ist kalt sie ist nicht geladen und
die die die staatsanwältin hat sich ja
sehr vorsichtig geäußert die
ermittlungen dauern an wir haben im
vorfeld der pressekonferenz auch schon
gehört dass es sich da noch um sechs bis
zehn wochen handeln kann es tatsächlich
eine eventuelle anklage erhoben wird du
hast gerade geschildert dass es auch
unmut gab offenbar über die zustände am
set wie genau es am set ausgesehen hat
und was genau passiert ist das fasst
thomas kann ja nochmal für uns zusammen
eine stille andacht am sonntag in
burbank kalifornien hunderte menschen
trauern gedenken der kamerafrau elina
hutchins gefeiert als besonderes talent
mutter eines sohnes aus dem leben
gerissen mit 42 jahren
es geschah vor knapp einer woche an
diesem film set in santa fe new mexico
gedreht wird der western rast
hauptdarsteller alec baldwin probt eine
szene mit einer waffe kurz darauf den
notruf eines crew mitglieds
wir brauchen dringend einen krankenwagen
sofort zur bonanza creek ranch wir haben
geprobt dann gehen die waffe los wir
sind alle davon gerannt
der schuss verletzt den regisseur joel
sousa und er trifft elena hutchins
tödlich baldwin äußert sich in einem
tweet es gibt keine worte um einen
schock und meine trauer auszudrücken
über den tragischen unfall der eline
hutchins das leben genommen hat nach dem
polizeiverhör entstehen diese fotos
baldwin der star ein gebrochener mann
wer von der filmcrew ist verantwortlich
für das was geschah klar ist
mittlerweile die waffe war keine
requisite sondern echt die 24-jährige
waffen meisterin hatte zuvor erst einmal
an einem filmset gearbeitet und der
regieassistent dave holz soll zuvor nach
einem ähnlichen vorfall entlassen worden
sein 2009 10 bei einem anderen film
außerdem sollen angeblich crewmitglieder
in film pausen mit scharfer munition auf
bierdosen geschossen haben nicht zuletzt
im fokus alec baldwin selbst der auch
produzent des films ist die fragen waren
die sicherheitsvorkehrungen beim dreh zu
lax wer trägt die verantwortung für den
tod einer frau
tja das gilt es nun also zu klären nina
niebergall in washington wie geht es
dann alec baldwin im moment gibt es
solidaritätsbekundungen aus der szene
für ihnen kollegen die damit gefühle
äußern oder erlebt er gerade einen
schutzraum
alec baldwin hat sich seit freitag nicht
mehr öffentlich geäußert da hat er ja
diesen tweet abgesetzt gesagt dass er
geschockt ist und traurig ist vom
wochenende sind bekannt von ihm fotos wo
er sich mit dem ehemann von alina
hudgens und ihrem sohn getroffen hat
aber wie es ihm jetzt geht das weiß man
tatsächlich nicht es ist schon so dass
es wird also ich würde nicht sagen dass
es breite solidarität gibt mit ihm aber
es ist schon so dass es immer wieder
mitleidsbekundungen gibt auch mit ihm
heute morgen beispielsweise bei basieren
ende eine eine kamerafrau die gesagt hat
menschlich ist dann natürlich ein großes
mitgefühl weil er sicherlich
traumatisiert ist von dem was da
passiert ist aber gleichzeitig eben
immer auch die frage nach der
verantwortung und dann gibt es aber auch
diejenigen die ihn
angreifen zum teil auch lächerlich
machen dass das es zum zum vor allem von
von rechter seite zu beobachten donald
trump junior ganz vorneweg der teilt bei
bei instagram beispielsweise bilder und
mims die alec baldwin lächerlich machen
denn alec baldwin das wissen ja vieles
bekannt geworden auch durch saturday
night live wo er jahrelang den
ehemaligen us präsidenten donald trump
parodiert hat
dann bleiben wir mal bei seiner rolle
als produzent halligalli schreibt hier
über youtube werden alec baldwin
produzent verträgt er wohl auch die
verantwortung dass alles glatt läuft und
niemand zu schaden kommt schätze ich was
ist denn mit den vorwürfen dass es eine
billigproduktion war und ist dass an
vielen stellen gespart wurde dass teile
des teams gestreikt haben dass teile des
teams das set verlassen haben und nicht
weiter arbeiten wollten unter diesen
bedingungen wie wird das diskutiert in
den usa
ja man kann davon ausgehen das da am set
irgendwas nicht ganz richtig lief also
tatsächlich das ist ja gerade schon
gesagt haben wohl mehrere crewmitglieder
kameraleute wohl das set tatsächlich
auch verlassen weil sie gegen die
arbeitsbedingungen und wohl auch gegen
die sicherheit am set protestieren
wollten und es also aus der ganzen
filmbranche äußern sich jetzt immer
wieder auch leute die sagen solche low
budget produktionen können gefährlich
werden zum einen eben weil wenn die wenn
die filmcrew zu lange arbeitet wenn sie
keine pausen macht wenn sie zu wenig
geld bekommt wenn sie zu lange anfahrten
hat je schwieriger die bedingungen desto
schneller können natürlich fehler
passieren und noch umso schlimmer wenn
eben die sicherheitsprotokolle nicht
eingehalten werden und auch da wird
immer wieder die kritik oder der der
bedenken punkt geäußert dass eben auch
genau das vielleicht an dieser stelle
aus spargründen nicht der fall war geht
denn die diskussion auch noch weiter
dahin gehen dass man diese
sicherheitsvorkehrungen verschärfen
sollte dass man da neue bessere anderer
regeln braucht
also man muss jetzt natürlich sagen dass
in diesem fall also was da jetzt
passiert ist scheint aktuell alles
darauf hinzudeuten dass die
sicherheitsvorkehrungen oder die
sicherheitsregeln dies die cia gibt die
auch recht streng sind einfach nicht
eingehalten wurden und zwar an vielen
vielen stellen aber es gibt durchaus die
diskussion ob echte waffen an einem
filmset überhaupt noch genutzt werden
sollen das ist im moment noch der fall
da geht es häufig darum um eine gewisse
echtheit authentizität auch darum dass
der satz der das der schauspieler auch
das echt rüber bringen kann dass er die
schwere der waffe spürt die in den
lufthauch der patrone spürt et cetera
und da gibt es eben auch stimmen die
jetzt sagen das muss doch im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert alles
nicht mehr sein wir können das alles
sehr echt auch als requisiten waffe
nachbauen und da hat beispielsweise
jetzt ein regisseur
eine petition gestartet die auch schon
60.000 unterschied bekommen hat um die
genau eben das fordert keine echten
waffen mehr ans filmset vielen dank nina
niebergall nach washington und das ist
eine ganz wunderbare überleitung zu
unserem experten denen wir jetzt bei uns
hier in der sendung begrüßen das ist der
waffenmeister oliver rasch gelernt
büchsenmacher er arbeitet bei
zahlreichen deutschen film- und
fernsehproduktionen mit und schaut dass
schuss szenen sicher inszeniert sind und
werden rasch das was die kollegin in
amerika gerade beschrieben hat die
diskussion darum echte waffen am set
oder nur noch requisiten waffen wie
stehen sie dazu und können sie auch noch
mal erklären wo die unterschiede sind
dann fange ich erst mal mit den
unterschieden an echt waffen sagt schon
der begriff das ist eine echte waffe ist
dass ich also auch echte munition
verschießen kann und dann gibt es
verschiedene abstufungen es gibt keine
deko waffen die haben überhaupt gar
keine funktion die können gar nichts die
sehen nur schön aus dann haben wir die
klassischen schreckschusswaffen die auch
jeder frei ab 18 erwerben kann und wir
haben einen ganz kleinen anteil an
rainer film waffen es gibt ganz wenige
firmen die reine film waffen herstellen
ja und dann haben wir die echten waffen
wie zu anfang schon gesagt und die
echten waffen benutzen wir halt dann
wenn wir gar nicht die möglichkeit haben
auf andere zurückzugreifen weil es jetzt
gerade bei so einer western geschichte
diese unter hebel repetieren diese
gewehre die es da gibt die gibt es gar
nicht als schuss fähig oder als
platzpatronen fähig als nachbauten und
dann haben wir noch das sprachen sie ja
auch an man versucht es authentisch zu
halten die ältere revolver die man
früher hatte auch diese gibt es so nicht
film tauglich als nachbauten und dann
greifen wir bei sowas echt waffen zurück
das heißt ja nicht so richtig verstehe
ich komme um echte waffen im film
eigentlich gar nicht drum herum wenn ich
gute filme machen möchte
unter den jetzigen gegebenheiten würde
es anders nicht funktionieren das heißt
wir haben echte waffen und in diesem
fall wie wir jetzt gelernt haben auch
scharfe munition
das ist was was hier im chat für viel
unverständnis sorgt felix gehen alle
fragt zum beispiel was zum teufel hat
schuss fähige munition an einem filmset
zu suchen sie als experte können sie das
einschätzen für amerika und im
unterschied dann auch vielleicht zu
deutschland oder es an beiden orten
gleich das an filmsets keine scharfe
munition erlaubt es
in deutschland ist es nicht erlaubt es
macht doch gar keinen sinn in
deutschland würde es nie passieren dass
die crew in der mittagspause schießen
geht weil das vom gesetz her in
deutschland gar nicht zulässig ist sie
dürfen in deutschland auf einem
schießstand schießen der spezielle für
abgenommen und genehmigt oder sie sind
jäger und schießen auf der jagd diese
zwei anwendungsbeispiele gibt es in
deutschland für den scharfen schuss bei
filmaufnahmen macht ein scharfer schuss
gar keinen sinn auch nicht wenn keiner
im bild wäre beispielsweise wenn man
sagt wir schießen durch eine türen
wollen das filmen oder wir schießen auf
ein auto dieser effekt wäre viel zu
schwach ja der zuschauer würde das gar
nicht richtig wahrnehmen und das wird
dann hielt mit hilfe von pyrotechnik und
spezialeffekten aufgeputscht das bild
und wir haben das was wir wollen der
scharfe schuss macht keinen sinn und in
deutschland ein absolutes no-go und wir
haben auch keine scharfe munition an
einem filmset wie ist es mit scharfer
munition in amerika
das weiß ich nicht ich weiß nicht ob das
dort normal ist oder ob das an der
gegend lag dass man sagt sie na ja
vielleicht new mexico ist ein bisschen
lockerer und wir haben jetzt die wüste
wir könnten da noch ein paar
schießübungen machen in deutschland wäre
es wie ich sagte verboten in amerika ist
es vielleicht gang und gäbe aber ich
weiß von produktionen beispielsweise aus
anderen ländern auch in krisengebieten
wird ja auch schon mal gedreht und da
gibt es in der tat dann auch scharfe
munition am set oftmals zum unmut der
darstelle und der ganzen crew aber auch
das gibt es und das ist gar nicht
unbedingt amerika das kann auch im
ehemaligen jugoslawien passieren oder in
anderen ländern die gar nicht so weit
von uns entfernt sind nach dem was sie
über diesen fall wissen können sie sich
vorstellen dass das genau so war wie sie
gerade beschrieben haben die crew hat in
der pause mit scharfer munition
geschossen oder wie der user jackie dort
zum beispiel schreibt hallo liebes
zdf-team es wird ja gemunkelt dass tage
zuvor beim ausflug mit scharfer munition
hantiert wurde von diesem ausflug sind
auch die letzten videoaufnahmen von
halyna hudgens auf dem pferd ist da was
dran können sie sich vorstellen dass das
genau auch das problem für diesen unfall
war dass die waffe eben noch scharf
geladen war und die waffen meisterin
jung und unerfahren und das nicht
gemerkt hat
es gibt im grunde um drei möglichkeiten
aus meiner sicht wie das hätte passieren
können wir haben ja auch immer so ein
bisschen gehört in den letzten tagen es
kam zu einer sogenannten fehlzündung
jetzt muss man sich vorstellen sondern
wolle wird geladen mit patronen es kommt
zu einer fehlzündung fehlzündung
bedeutet eventuelle störungen im abbrand
also im umsetzungen in der umsetzung des
schusses das würde bedeuten dass ein
geschoss zwar die patrone verlässt aber
den lauf nicht mehr verlässt es ist so
schwach dass das projektil in den lauf
eingetrieben wird wir haben einen
stecker einen steckschuss aber die hülse
lässt sich noch frei wieder rausnehmen
und jetzt hätten wir ein projektil in
einem lauf und eventuell kommt dann eine
platzpatrone hinterher die dann das zu
ende bringt was die patrone vorher nicht
gemacht hat und zwar das projekt jedoch
sind auch schießen dass wir die eine
möglichkeit die zweite möglichkeit ist
diese western waffen die wir verwenden
oder die dort verwendet wurden
viele kennen vielleicht den aufbau eines
revolvers ich kann die trommel komplett
in gänze bei modernen revolver zur seite
ausschwenken das heißt ich habe sofort
visuell erfasst die waffe ist leer es
gibt noch revolver die lassen sich
abkippen genau das gleiche ich sehe die
gesamte trommel den den trommeln boden
und sehe die waffe ist leer bei so einem
western revolver ist dass eine kammer
die ich seit nicht über eine klappe
öffnen und jetzt jede kammer für sich
drehen muss und jede kammer
kontrollieren muss im regelfall sind es
sechs kammern wenn ich das aufgrund
einer flüchtigkeit nur fünf patronen
rausnehmen und die sechste vergesse dann
sehe ich dass eventuell gar nicht lade
dann irgendwann platzpatronen rein und
stelle auch gar nicht fest mensch ich
habe jetzt nur fünf platzpatronen
geladen anstatt sechs und dann würde das
bedeuten dass dann eine original patrone
in der waffe sein könnte
man weiß es nicht es ist halt alles
spekulativ aber das sind so die dinge
wenn man jetzt mit den experten spricht
auch in deutschland was kann passiert
sein oder das letzte was passiert sein
kann das wirklich völlig ungeachtet eine
scharfe waffe in komplett scharfen
zustand mit kompletter auf munitionieren
in irgendwelche aus irgendwelchen
gründen an den schauspieler gegangen ist
sie wurde dann vielleicht komplett
verwechselt mit einer waffe die man
eigentlich für die schießübungen nehmen
wollte das was sie gerade im mittelteil
beschrieben haben ist ja sehr komplex
wenn man jetzt als 24 jährige
expertin in diesem fall am set ist kann
es sein dass sie nicht genügend
erfahrung hatte oder kann das sein dass
ein solcher flüchtigkeitsfehler oder was
auch immer das war auch einem sehr
erfahrenen kollegen passieren könnte
also so ein flüchtigkeitsfehler der darf
nicht passieren
ob das an dem alter liegt weiß ich nicht
ja ich möchte mir auch kein urteil
darüber erlauben mit 24 jahren
sie kommt aus einer familie die sehr
erfahren ist gerade in diesen bereichen
ich schätze schon dass die auch eine
gewisse erfahrung hatte und auch mit
ihren 24 jahren ob das auf grund ihres
alters ihrer fähigkeiten ich weiß es
nicht was dazu führte vielleicht wurde
sie abgelenkt man weiß es nicht also da
kann man wirklich auch nur darüber
spekulieren und das bringt uns nicht
weiter dann lassen sie uns lieber über
ihre arbeit sprechen als waffenmeister
wenn sie waffen verwenden in filmen
können sie mal beschreiben mit was für
waffen sie da in der regel operieren und
was sie machen bevor ein schauspieler
überhaupt diese waffe in die hand
bekommt und damit dann vor der kamera
agiert
also die waffen die bei mir verwendung
finden das ist alles was es gibt an
schusswaffen also ich arbeite mit
scharfen waffen ich arbeite mit reinen
film waffen ich arbeite mit
spezialwaffen die nur durch als die als
kriegswaffe gelten die nochmal ganz
besonders genehmigt werden müssen und es
gibt eine vielzahl an waffen wenn ich
jetzt an den set komme und wir haben ein
bild wo es heißt es fällt ein schuss ja
wir schießen ja in deutschland relativ
selten am set und auch nicht so häufig
also von der menge der schüsse her ich
gebe es ein klassisches beispiel wir
haben eine szene wo der kommissar einen
warnschuss in die luft ab geht dann wird
bevor dieser schuss stattfindet ist das
im vorfeld besprochen worden mit der
regie wir haben uns eine waffe überlegt
wir haben uns überlegt wie das bild
aufgebaut wird am eigentlichen drehort
bekommt der schauspieler noch mal ein
ganz kurzes briefing zu der waffe da
geht es hier um seine sicherheit und b
geht es natürlich um die glaubwürdigkeit
der schauspieler muss die waffe so
bedienen dass wir da einen polizisten
spielt dass wir ihnen das auch glauben
können und wenn wir jetzt in die
schutzzone reinkommen dann wird die
ganze crew nochmal gebiet weil er auch
jeder einen gehörschutz bekommt
einschließlich schauspieler die kriegen
kleine in ohr gehört schütze dann legen
wir die kamerapositionen fest wenn man
eine pistole haben wissen wir wir haben
den auswurf einer patronenhülse dann
schauen wir mal wo die hinfliegt die ist
zwar nicht gefährlich aber eventuell
unangenehm auch da schauen wir wo hin
fällt diese hülse dann wird die waffe
geladen von mir kommt eine platzpatrone
rein und wenn das ergibt einen schuss ab
kommt auch nur eine platzpatrone in die
waffe und kurz bevor dann der schuss
stattfindet wird nochmal laut am set
angesagt es findet ein schuss statt je
nachdem wo wir schießen haben wir zuvor
noch die polizei informiert dass keine
erschrockenen bürger bei der polizei
anrufen ja dann kommen wir in die shows
sehen in der schauspieler kriegt von mir
die waffe er weiß dass er so wenn du von
mir kommt überprüft wurde das soweit
alles okay ist und er schießt und mit
dem schuss ist meistens das bild dann im
kasten dann wird abgebrochen in dem
moment bzw dann geht die waffe wieder an
mich ich mache die klassischen
sicherheitsüberprüfungen an der waffe
und entweder wiederholen wir ist oder
wir haben dass bildung kasten an der
stelle wo sie gesagt haben und er
schießt möchte ich gerne noch mal einen
haken mit einer frage von einem user
namens guter künstler der fragt
schießt man direkt auf leute das muss
doch nicht sein der schauspieler kann
doch auch vorbei schießen ohne dass der
zuschauer merkt
das ist richtig man kann ganz leicht
immer an der kamera vorbei schießen
dahinter steht dann aber trotzdem
meistens noch jemand wenn es nicht der
kameramann oder die kamerafrau ist steht
dann vielleicht der schärfen ziehe auch
da sagen wir natürlich stellt euch so
auf dass das nicht sein muss aber es
kann immer mal passieren wir müssen uns
vorstellen der schauspieler hat da eine
rolle zu bedienen er hat eventuell einen
text zu bedienen ich sage ihnen gewisse
dinge im vorfeld es ist aber durchaus
möglich dass er auch ein bisschen was
wieder vergessen hat in dem moment und
dann darf trotzdem niemand hinter der
kamera tot umfallen also das ist normal
ein zusätzlicher punkt den wir als
sicherheitsaspekt hinein bringen können
aber auf den können uns nicht verlassen
ich würde gerne darüber sprechen dass es
vorwürfe an alec baldwin als produzenten
gibt weil es eine billigproduktion sein
soll dieser film weil es heißt es wurden
kosten gespart der druck auf das team
war sehr hoch es gibt berichte über
unmut im team leute haben das set
verlassen es wurde gestreikt erleben sie
das auch dass es immer schwierigere
produktionsbedingungen gibt die auch sie
in ihrer arbeit so unter druck setzen
dass man den aspekt der sicherheit am
ende eher vernachlässigt um kosten zu
sparen ist das eine gefahr auch in
deutschland
nein also den aspekt der sicherheit
lassen wir nicht außer acht wir lassen
eventuell meinem bild fallen ja dass man
einfach sagt es ist jetzt zu teuer nur
große schießerei zu machen das bild wird
gesprächen aber von den
sicherheitsaspekten bleibt alles beim
alten ich würde das in diesem fall jetzt
auch sagen es war eine waffe meisterin
vor ort und ob die jetzt viel geld
gekriegt hat oder wenig geld die wirte
ihren job trotzdem gemacht haben an dem
tag vielleicht hätte man ihr noch einen
assistenten assistentin zur seite
stellen können was aber auch eigentlich
nicht üblich ist also ich glaube was die
kosten betrifft das hat mit diesem
unfall wenig zu tun erleben sie es dass
regisseure produzenten immer krassere
bilder produzieren wollen um mehr
zuschauer für die filme zu kriegen
ja es gibt schon mal die idee größere
bilder zu machen und wir also ich sage
immer wir weil es ist ja meistens die
waffe irgendwo für dieses krasse bild da
dann kommt pyrotechnik ins spiel die
stuntleute kommen ins spiel das ist ja
ein großes zusammenspiel von
verschiedenen gewerken und wir beraten
dann den den den regisseur oder den
produzenten wir überlegen uns gemeinsam
ja wie können wir was besonderes
produzieren und dann wird das umgesetzt
wenn das machbar ist aber es macht
keiner was und sagt na ja es ist
eigentlich super gefährlich aber wir
machen es trotzdem
also das passiert nicht
film ist teamarbeit sie haben das auch
gerade angedeutet jetzt sagt der
schauspieler ulrich matthes im
zusammenhang mit dieser geschichte ich
bin schon oft erschossen worden im film
und auf der bühne ich kenne den druck
den man spürt wenn mit platzpatronen auf
den eigenen körper geschossen wird ich
hatte nie ein schlechtes gefühl dabei
das ist jetzt anders ich werde von nun
an immer unangenehme empfindungen haben
wenn im film auf mich geschossen wird
für sie als waffenmeister welche
herausforderung bedeutete dieser fall
mit alec baldwin jetzt
noch viel mehr aufklärung am set und
dann die zeit werde ich mir dann auch
zusätzlich nehmen gerade wenn fragen von
seiten des schauspielers oder das
schauspielern kommen dann werde ich dann
noch mal ganz genau die waffe erklären
die technik erklären wir werden noch mal
ganz genau in dieses bild gehen wenn es
erforderlich ist ja ich verstehe dass
das diese leute sagen oh das ist jetzt
ein unangenehmes gefühl ja aber ich
glaube einfach da müssen wir uns einfach
darüber im klaren sein es passiert noch
andere sachen am set ja es werden auch
schauspieler von hunden gebissen wo es
heißt auch der hund der macht nichts
diese schauspieler sind ab dem tag
gebrandmarkt kinder in der arbeit mit
hunden ja also wir dürfen uns jetzt
nicht alle auf dieses tragische ereignis
stürzen und sagen jetzt können wir nicht
mehr weitermachen unfälle passieren und
es wird auch leider nicht der letzte
unfall an dem set gewesen sein
sagt der waffenmeister oliver rasch
vielen dank für das gespräch für diese
sehr eindrucksvollen schilderungen ihrer
arbeit für ihre einschätzung danke schön
herr rasch und danke an sie für die
vielen zahlreichen fragen von denen wir
hier leider nur einen bruchteil
beantworten konnten ich sehe das aber
ich hoffe unser community management
kann da auch noch ein bisschen mithelfen
und ich bedanke mich für die rege
beteiligung und wünsche ihnen und euch
noch ein schönen restlichen abend
tschüss
[Musik]